it's a messy chaos on the frontlines of
Tripoli many of the revolution fighters
have picked up arms again and some are
clearly a bit rusty
there's little binding of them together
just a desire to keep back the forces
outside led by former Gaddafi general
there are a myriad of different fighting
groups who've banded together to stop
general hectares forces entering the
capital but it's messy and very
disorganized the prospects of peace
talks look very far away at this point
and Hefner's forces have some powerful
friends
including Russia Egypt and the UAE
[Applause]
shifting as they take land then get
pushback then put forward again there
are at least four battle sites like this
one in different parts of the capital
the fighting has trapped thousands of
civilians and terrified families this is
in the middle of a residential area
the fighters here are supporting the
government recognized by the UN but
they're feeling terribly exposed that
whoosh was the sound of a rocket coming
in the other side has big backers and
heavy weaponry but eight years after
their dictator Colonel Gadhafi was
topping Italy with the help of
specifically Britain and France they're
furious at the legacy they've left
behind
but all this instability is leaving a
vacuum for is gangs and militia to
flourish
and of course Libya's civilians are
stuck in the middle of it your tank or
their attack so we stay or we go go okay
they're saying we should go they don't
like the fact that they have got far
bigger weaponry far bigger okay help us
get out because they reckon we need to
get out of here quickly and they go
through this sometimes several times a
day and the international community
seems frozen with inertia over what to
do
Alex Crawford Sky News